one of the challenges of good times
is it breathes laziness
right
think about let's like the cable company
like when you have a monopoly i mean how
much do you really have to give them
it's not like they can go anywhere right
so the worst customer service the worst
products are usually the ones that have
a monopoly position because there's just
no there's no competition there's no
there's no reason to push or challenge
or do better
um other than just goodwill i guess
um
uh uh and so i think when when times
were good um we get lazy because if you
leave there'll be someone else to take
give us your business you know it'll be
fine
i think in hard times where where the
stresses are higher because there's
there is less business i think it forces
us to actually go back to the base
basics of what it means to run a good
business and the best customers are the
loyal ones um the ones who will stick
with you through thick and thin
um and so when you engage in
relationship building when you when you
act in a trustworthy manner when just
like just like i gave the tribal example
before when we as customers get a sense
that you would sacrifice your interest
to take care of us we'll give you our
love and our loyalty and pay you a
premium um you know when when when you
when you go back to nordstrom's um
and you have a sweater from
bloomingdale's and you're like can i
return this please they'll take it back
um and the reason they'll take it back
is because it's fine so they'll lose
money on the sweater but they made you
incredibly happy
this is a decision they made
so i think one of the things that it's
revealed right now is that we have to
bring our a-game that we don't get to be
lazy anymore um and also relying on
manipulation just
it it's good for the short term but not
for the long term so examples of
manipulation are things like dropping
the price having a pro promotion the
pressure sell you know buy one get one
free these are all mechanisms to get
someone to buy but they don't do
anything to help someone be loyal they
just they just add they add uh the
promise of bounty or the threat of
punishment um inspiration is different
it's it's it's making someone feel heard
make someone feel good making somebody
feel like they matter let me give you an
example um uh so we've all had this
experience back in the pre-covered days
where you get done with a business trip
early and you want to go home early
right you can you can go home a day
early so you pick up the phone you call
the airline
and you say hey my business just got
done early
i checked online
and it seems that you do have a flight
available the day before can i please
get on that flight
and the uh the customer service agent
says um i'm sorry you have the wrong
class of ticket i can't put you on that
flight you say please i just i just i
don't want to sit in the hotel room i
want to go back to my family i know you
have seats available please please can
you put me i'll pay whatever change fees
please can you just put me in my flight
i'm exhausted i'm sorry sir i've
explained it to you you have the wrong
class of ticket there's nothing i can do
right
now let's change that to some a more
empathetic customer focus standpoint hey
i'm i'm done with my business trip early
can i go home early i notice you have
seats available can i get on that flight
uh here's the problem sir
you've got the run class a ticket so the
computer won't let me do it let me see
what i can do i want to get you i want
to get you home hold on click click
click click no that didn't work come on
i'm going to try we're going to get you
home we're going to get you on that
flight hold on sir click click click
click click click
no that didn't work hold on sir let me
just talk to my to my supervisor they
may know something i don't know you hold
for a second they come back sir i am so
sorry i want to get you home to your
family the computer just won't let me do
it because of your class of ticket i am
so sorry you know what no worries don't
worry thank you so much for looking
the same result
and this is the problem which is for
you we usually judge customer service
like if i got what i want it's good
customer service if i didn't get what i
wanted bad customer service that's only
half the that's only half the formula
half the formula is how we make someone
feel and does the customer service agent
actually care about the human being on
the other side of that phone
and that goes for everything it's not
just customer service but do we actually
care about the person we're trying we
claim to be serving we we call it
customer service well the word serve is
in there
rather than take or selfish or explain
or rationalize i work in customer
rationalization that actually would be
more accurate for most customer service
departments um and so i think that idea
of of treating people and seeing people
as people um um and trying to and trying
to help people live better lives i think
i think we're seeing it and i think
that's a very good thing not because i
think there's some sort of renaissance
now i think it's because we got lazy for
a bunch of years and now we're having to
go back to basics